hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about the 80 20
rule in language learning and
what i don't think is useful about the
80 20 rule and what i think is useful
the 80 20 rule this is the pareto
principle that 20 of your activity will
give you 80
of your result
by the way two things to point out here
or to say first of all if you enjoy
these videos about language learning
please subscribe to my channel and
second of all i'm going to at the end of
this discussion show you a brief uh
interview or
portion of my lesson with my one of my
ukrainian tutors
so you can listen to that if you're
interested and i will tell you later on
what i talk about i'm not going to
produce subtitles all right
now a number of people have asked me for
example to tell them what i do in my
discussions with my tutors so i will
explain that a little bit but first
let's get to this idea of the 80 20
principle some people say if you learn a
very small number of words that is going
to help you
learn the language that gives you 80 of
the language i don't believe that all
right
what i do believe is that you should
spend 80 of your time
on
big picture what i call
top-down
listening and reading engaging with the
language doing interesting things in the
language and 20 of your time on the nuts
and bolts which is grammar which is
practicing grammar
so that a very small percentage and in
particular this idea that the you should
learn the most common words of the
language first i mean you can if you
want to but it's not necessary because
those most common words are going to
show up
very often as soon as you start engaging
with the language where i do think it's
useful
is if you whatever language you're
learning if you go and google for the
100 most common verbs in the language
not nouns because that'll depend on your
interest but the verbs in the language
if you master those if you really learn
how they're used
and you won't do that on the first pass
through you won't begin by learning the
100 most common verbs but it's something
that you can go back to all the time and
make sure that you know how to use those
100 most common verbs that i think is
quite useful and i'm starting to do more
and more of that and i think that's for
example where pyotr's simple stories in
polish real polish dot pl are very good
because a lot of his stories go over the
use of the most common
uh
verbs in the language that is very
helpful however
the bulk of my learning activity is
engaging with things that are
interesting as i said earlier i have to
begin with the simple you know 30-second
stuff in the starter books
and and i often i should say i didn't
say that i often go back to the starting
books time and time again because again
it's that 20 of time that you spend with
the nuts and bolts uh which could be
going over again those lessons in the
starter book or listening to simple
stories like pyotr store stories in
polish which i do from time to time to
kind of refresh
my grasp of some of the basic verbs and
and things in the language but 80 of my
time is spent on things that are
interesting
and and
that then gets the subject of how i use
my
sessions with my tutors as you know i
wait until i'm able to understand and
that i wait until i have some words
and so then my sessions with my tutors
are simply discussions discussions about
whatever interests us and
if i find that a tutor is not
interesting cannot have maintain a
conversation then i don't continue with
that tutor or occasionally i'll get a
sort of quote professional tutor who
tells me today we're going to do the
numbers
i don't go back to that tutor i'm not
interested in that i'm interested in
having a general discussion after which
the tutor sends me a list of all the
phrases and and words that i had trouble
with and then i studied them and so as
an example of that now
of that 80 percent focus on interesting
things that listen to and read and then
in the discussion again focus on
interesting things
uh so i'm going to show you now a
discussion with katarina who is my tutor
in nepro nippo nipro petrovsk in ukraine
who is a very interesting person and we
have had very interesting discussions on
history she gave me some links to
very interesting his ukrainian
historians she works as a historian as
an archaeologist teaches at the
university she's involved with a
volunteer organization that helps
particularly displaced persons people
displaced by the war in ukraine
helps them obtain grants from
international organizations it helps
them uh set up businesses if they had a
business in donetsk can they move now to
nipro she helps them
get money or other resources that can
help them do that and so we discuss that
in this uh lesson so you're going to see
a few minutes of my ukrainian lesson
with catherine and you'll see how
interesting it is to engage with
interesting people in the language and
the actual nuts and bolts of the
language i still have to work on i have
to work on them and i spend 10 15 20 of
my time trying to nail those things down
but that just takes time and
ultimately it's that combination of of
80 doing interesting things in the
language
20
maximum with the nuts and bolts that
eventually enable you to become uh
hopefully
if not fluent at least comfortable in
the language so thank you for listening
and now if you want you can listen to
the ukrainian discussion with katarina
[Music]
you